[Music]
they're long-time rivals in the comics
but spider-man failed to appear in
venom's solo big screen debut
why isn't this a marvel movie well kinda
the answer is actually a lot more
complicated than that if you want to
know the real reason why spider-man's
not in the venom movie we gotta talk
some business
house divided marvel movies didn't
really become marvel movies as you know
them until 2008's iron man
in the 1990s marvel's movie making
division was still trying to convince
hollywood that movies and tv shows based
on its comic books might be something
worth looking into
since it had no direct leverage in the
film industry marvel farmed its
properties out to anyone who would take
a chance on using them
this is how fox ended up making the
x-men and the fantastic four movies
how universal ended up in charge of the
hulk and why spider-man and his amazing
spider friends ended up in the hands of
sony
this is how things used to be but the
success of iron man and the birth of
marvel studios
changed all that getting the mighty
marvel movie party in motion
marvel studios has since been acquired
by disney which more recently began the
process of acquiring fox
which brings a large chunk of the marvel
characters back under one roof
except for sony's spider people and
that's where things get dicey
none of this makes sense
an amazing spider plan the same year
that marvel studios took its burgeoning
cinematic universe to the next level
with the avengers
sony rebooted its spider-man franchise
with the amazing spider-man
and sony's plans didn't stop with peter
parker in an effort to compete with the
rising mcu
sony began laying track for its own
cinematic universe set in the world of
spider-man's new york
during the production of amazing
spider-man 2 reports emerged that sony
was developing a movie based
on the villain team the sinister six
there were also rumors of a potential
venom spin-off as well as a prequel
movie focusing on a young aunt may
a mind-boggling proposition both then
and also now
wait wait wait what are you doing what
are you doing what are you doing no i do
the longer i'm doing my laundry no i do
the laundry
none of it panned out once the amazing
spider-man sequel debuted to a franchise
low performance
leading sony to re-evaluate its entire
approach to the spider-man property
in doing so they leaned into a classic
survival strategy
if you can't beat them join them
homecoming
by 2014 sony and marvel were officially
in talks to collaborate on producing a
second spider-man reboot
talks which ultimately culminated in
2017's spider-man homecoming
the team-up arrangement sported benefits
for both parties
creatively the arrangement allowed
marvel studios to use spider-man in its
own mcu stories
while sony got to reap some profits off
of marvel's golden touch
the deal has been reported to cover the
production of five movies total
with the fifth being 2019 spider-man far
from home
after that no one's really sure what's
gonna happen either
sony will take back control of
spider-man or the studios will continue
to share him
in the meantime the finer details of who
gets to do what with which marvel
characters can be kind of confusing for
the rest of us
muddy in the waters in 2017 sony
announced the standalone movie for venom
one of the most famous marvel comics
characters that it owns the rights to
the announcement almost immediately
sparked confusion about the movie's
place in the mcu
if it had a place at all people wondered
would venom take place in the same world
as the iron man black panther
and the guardians of the galaxy or would
it be doing its own thing
even the people in charge of making the
movies couldn't get their story straight
when talking with the media
it was eventually cleared up that the
mcu would have nothing to do with the
movies that sony made on its own
basically marvel gets to handle the
live-action spider-man appearances
and everything sony does is sony's
business
rumors abound sony began making the
venom movie with tom hardy in the lead
drawing inspiration from a comic that
put the character in san francisco
his costume was also altered to remove
any traces of spider-man's arachnid dna
on top of that the movie's director
explicitly said that spider-man would
not be in the movie which should have
been the end of the debate
but rumors still persisted that
spider-man would appear
one of the more pervasive rumors claimed
that current spider-man actor tom
holland would be appearing in venom just
as peter parker and not suited up as
spider-man
the rumor most predominantly pushed by
collider's john schnepp
has a certain kind of logic to it after
all a peter parker appearance would mean
that all those denials of a spider-man
appearance would technically be correct
you are technically correct the best
kind of correct
s-u-m-c versus mcu of course as we all
know now neither spider-man peter parker
nor tom holland is anywhere near the
venom movie
as we saw it in theaters indeed venom is
the start of something new which sony
plans to use as a springboard for a new
attempt at a cinematic universe
according to variety the series is being
internally referred to
as sony's universe of marvel characters
which is
not a great name but hey it's what we've
got for now the question is
who's next sony is reportedly now in
development on several movies based on
the marvel comics characters to which it
owns the film rights
a number that variety puts at around 900
current movies and development include a
morbius the living vampire movie
starring jared leto
as well as movies based off the
characters jackpot black cat
craven the hunter night watch silk and
silver sable and those are just the ones
we know about
so will these movies actually come to
fruition probably not all of them
but the strong performance of venom
would seem to put the studio in a good
position for the future
spider-man or no spider-man